il y a jour pour jour 4 mois les
extraterrestres envahissaient notre
monde
nous avons souffert
nous avons sacrifié
des vies
des êtres aimés
connexion c'est le seul moyen que nous
aurons pu savoir ce qu'ils veulent
et de les arrêter de frapper
mes chers concitoyens mondiaux levez la
tête
ceci est notre ennemi tous ensemble nous
gagnerons cette guerre
les extraterrestres quelque chose nous a
connecté c'est peut-être la seule chance
qu'on est de s'en sortir
je sais que ça a l'air vraiment dingue
ça a l'air vraiment dingue mais le monde
entier dingue pas vrai
[Musique]
ils se sont adaptés on s'adaptera
imagine si tu pouvais sauver tout le
monde
[Musique]
quand on veut gagner la guerre on
riposte
les réponses
sont là
vous êtes sûr de vouloir y aller
[Musique]